[Musique]
du côté des banques européennes on
attaque 2022 avec le sourire avec la
banane même 2021 marquée des résultats
exceptionnels plus 62 % par rapport à
2020 selon le cabinet refi nitive leur
niveau de rentabilité aurait même
dépassé celui d'avant pandémie du coup
les banques se sentent pousser des ailes
et les montants mis de côté pour
prévenir d'éventuelles défaillances
chute de 68% en 2021
bref le secteur bancaire est en pleine
confiance et ça profite à tous enfin
tous tous sauf le client car
parallèlement à ses résultats record les
frais bancaires ont explosé en 2022 les
tarifs de free de comptes de virement en
agence et de retrait dans la zone euro
vont subir leur plus forte hausse
globale depuis cinq ans selon l'étude
annuelle de panne aura banques qui
pointe 1,5 pour cent d'augmentation
contre 0,6 pour cent entre 2020 et 2021
l'association de consommateurs s'est
élevée elle table sur une augmentation
de 2,5 pour cent sur deux des trois
profils de consommateurs sur lesquels
elle a travaillé
[Musique]